Starry Night says chances are aliens do
exist but if they're Advanced enough to
master space travel why would they be
crashing all over Earth like us they'd
likely have their top scientists and
astronauts working on these missions I'm
sorry the aliens aren't perfect okay I'm
sorry they're not perfect like you if we
have beings from other solar systems
visiting Earth all the time seems to be
a pretty frequent occurrence every once
in a while they're gonna have a crash
landing so they're not they're not
batting a thousand sorry about that and
you think you could sit there in
judgment well maybe they'd never visited
Earth before they don't know everything
there is to know about the atmosphere
about everything so they've never been
here things go a little bit wrong
they're pretty far from home you know so
it's hard to troubleshoot